What will be the effect of the Trump coup
riot on the future of the Republican Party?
And many of you asking me is at the end of
the Republican Party, this is not the end
of the Republican Party, the Republican Party.
And by that I mean the Republicans that remain
in the public eye.
They say that they are not people of substance.
OK, Lindsey Graham denounced Trump ism early
in the 2016 Republican primary and then he
embraced it and then he partially called out
some of the things Trump did.
But then he golfs with Trump and Brown noses
him all the time.
And just in these last two weeks before Trump
leaves, Lindsey Graham gave a sensible speech
on the floor of the House during that joint
session in counting the ballots, saying this
has to stop.
Joe Biden is president.
Ba ba ba ba ba.
And then within 48 hours was on Fox News pleading
mercy for Trump, who did the right thing and
shouldn't be impeached a second time.
So these people are of no substance.
These are weasels.
OK, Susan Collins, in a less cartoonish way.
How many times, as she said, well, I'm disappointed
in the president.
I'm very concerned with the president, and
then she never once votes to make anything
change.
So I expect that the Republican officials
that survive this, some simply won't.
The Republican officials that survive this
are going to weasel their way out with some
of the both side stuff combined with I did
denounce this one thing.
At this point, they're going to pay lip service
as necessary.
There's not going to be any real introspection.
It will be just attacks on Democrats and liberals.
And, you know, we're against violence type
of thing.
So the future of the Republican Party is going
to be determined not by the Republican elected.
We know what they're going to do.
It's going to depend on Republican voters.
Now, when I say that many of you will not
be optimistic and I understand why any party
whose electorate can be bamboozled into choosing
Trump in a primary and then voting for him
60 million, 60 something million people in
2016 and then 70 something million voting
for him in 2020 after everything we saw.
Yeah, I don't have high expectations for those
people either.
But but there is a degree of this was too
much that we are seeing among some Republicans.
I'm not talking the Cunanan insurrectionists
that still to this day are saying Antifa did
the riot.
I'm not talking about them.
They're probably beyond help.
But I am talking about people who would be
more in line with John McCain or Mitt Romney
or, you know, even somebody like William Weld,
the former Republican governor of Massachusetts,
to go back a little bit.
A lot of those folks see the difference between
what they believe and what Donald Trump brought
to the Republican Party.
And while I don't expect them to be political
allies in any real, substantive way on policy,
they may require some kind of bigger change
within the party, the Republican Party, that
would prevent another Trump from happening
again.
I'm not super optimistic.
I'm trying to give you the best case scenario.
And I. I think it's simply too early to know
it's you know, you don't know to say what's
the damage when when the hurricane is still
happening is difficult to say, you know, but
if on if on September 12th, we had said, what
is the full political impact of 9/11, it would
have been too early by that.
We didn't know yet.
Some of us you know, we may be suspected that
a war was coming, but we didn't know that
the U.S. would go to war with the wrong country
on September 12th, that it was too early.
So to some degree, it's just too early.
But I'm giving you some sense of what the
best case scenario might be.
We will be here with you next week for the
inauguration and swearing in of Joe Biden,
hopefully not for any violence.
I hope there isn't any.
We are off on Monday, Martin Luther King Day,
no show Monday.
Martin Luther King Day will be back with you
Tuesday and then Wednesday, live for the inauguration
as well.
I'll see everybody then enjoy the bonus show.
Remember to sign up at join Pakman dot com.